right Garrett is following this
presidential election like no other at
the age of 48 she's hoping to vote for
the first time this November like close
to 6 million other Americans
she has been denied that right until now
because she was once convicted of a
crime she says this was especially
painful for her when Barack Obama was
first elected president I was angry
because I couldn't vote but all my kids
and at the time my husband did and I
wanted to vote I was really sad because
it's the first black president and I
didn't have a voice the US has one of
the highest incarceration rates
worldwide and imposes more restrictions
on felons voting rights than most other
democracies lost vary from state to
state four states have a lifetime ban on
voting for convicted criminals Iowa
Kentucky Virginia and Florida seven
other states have lifelong voting bans
depending on the crime committed
most states withdraw felons right to
vote while they're serving their jail
sentence and also why they are on parole
and probation other states only limit
voting rights during incarceration only
New England states Vermont and Maine
have no restrictions swing state
Virginia has become the latest
battleground over felon voting rights in
April of this year the governor issued
an order to restore the voting rights of
all former felons who had completed
their parole and probation almost half
of the nearly eligible voters were
African American progressive voting
rights activists welcomed the policy
it's really about what kind of society
you want to have is an inclusive society
as a democratic society are all people
involved in making decisions or is it a
limited democracy for only the rich that
or the white or the powerful but
conservative politicians and activists
suit the governor over the order they
argued that Virginia law only allows the
governor to restore voting rights on an
individual case
case basis since 1830 Virginia has
restricted felons from voting no
governor has ever interpreted that power
to restore rights to be a blanket power
that can be just issued in the manner
that the governor has issued it the
Virginia Supreme Court declared the
governor's order unconstitutional but
Terry will likely still be allowed to
vote that's because the governor is now
individually restoring the right to vote
for over 200,000 ex-felons Terry
struggled with drug addiction for
decades and spent time in jail for
shoplifting but she's been in recovery
for 10 years and considers being able to
vote an important part of rehabilitation
I think I should have a right to vote
because I think I have a voice you know
I have an opinion it does matter to me
what happens in the elections you know I
shouldn't be judged for something I did
over a decade ago
Terry is hoping for an end to the
struggle over voting rights for felons
and that this November she can join her
family at the ballot box determining the
direction America is headed in